fire
hey everyone its Peter Brown standing in
for freelancer Don sass for his review
of World of Warcraft Legion with the new
Legion expansion for World of Warcraft
Blizzard continues its streak of
delivering the best contemporary MMO
mechanical design but also radically
alters the balance of power in Azeroth
for the first time since 2010's
Cataclysm it's a gamble that pays off
region finds Azeroth's greatest
existential threat making its first
returned since Burning Crusade with the
titular demonic legion breathing down
the necks of orcs and man alike although
the Alliance and the Horde combined
forces at the expansion's beginning to
turn back the tide of this invasion
their attempts are crushed you're then
tasked with finding the pillars of
creation your only hope of closing the
portals to the twisting nether
unless you've invested in almost two
decades worth of Warcraft lore that all
may sound confusing
although purchasing Legion gives players
of free character boost to level 100 the
new starting level for the expansion
it's clear that Legion exists for WoW
score playerbase
it's fortunate then that the twists and
major emotional beats of Legion will
mean something to those players who have
been with the game since its early days
Legion starts off with a couple
impactful tragedies and doesn't pull any
punches from their characters you've
known since was inception aren't safe
the demonic corruption of the Legion
takes major lore heroes from the series
RTS days and turns them into tragic
villains by the end of the expansions
basic PvE content you're given a
first-hand look at the mana addiction
that ruptured elven society and invited
Legion to Azeroth in the first place
to the ruin of the world as destruction
drew ever closer a desperate choice was
made to weather stemming the corruption
of the Emerald Dream in ball Shara
uniting Torian tribes in high mountain
or battling the resurgent Naga in a
Sunnah this expansions new zones are
built around straightforward goals you
rarely have to question why you must
kill this or collect that and the sense
of busy work that Wow's basic quest can
often engender is thankfully absent you
get to play a part in shaping not just
the fight against the legion but new
societies you discover as well Wow has a
rich lore behind it that isn't always
integrated well into its gameplay the
legion doesn't have that problem the
expansions new class health system also
finds ways to integrate Wow's lower into
the game in meaningful ways each class
and subclass has its own artifact weapon
that can be acquired at the beginning of
the expansion which levels throughout
the rest of play and odds are that
veteran players are familiar with them
already adding to their innate appeal as
legendary weapons and it doesn't hurt
that legions new zones are positively
gorgeous Wow is running a modified
engine that's over a decade old and
while you can tell you're playing a game
based on old tech Legion displays
newfound scale and color working in
broad but memorable aesthetic strokes
the Nordic cliff scythes and towering
sculptures of storm hime bring a
richness to the zones hyperbolic Viking
fantasy while Shara is the heart of
Azeroth original world tree and is a
sprawling overrun forest teeming with
both life and corruption and legions
final leveling zone sir amar is awash in
a sea of psychedelic purples oranges and
reds that speak to its place as the
heart of the plague currently consuming
Azeroth
the new class the demon hunter doesn't
change things too much in terms of the
game's traditional Holy Trinity of tank
healer DPS but it adds a new exciting
wrinkle demon hunters can double jump
and glide across landscapes and it gives
them such a degree of mobility that all
of the other classes feel sluggish and
restrained in comparison few things in
Legion proved to be more satisfying than
avoiding a lengthy walk by just leaping
off a cliff and diving to a new
destination as massive demon wings
sprout from your characters back Legion
also includes some of Wow's best non
heroic non raid dungeon design in years
almost from the start dungeons require
actual coordination and teamwork region
also offers a host of bosses with more
complex movesets to manage an engagement
types to tackle unfortunately players
who want to roll an alternate character
or start Wow for the first time and
experience it in its entirety have to
play through the Burning Crusade and
Lich King content which this aren't half
as smartly designed as wow in its
current incarnation Blizzard keeps
getting better at what it does but six
expansions in it shouldn't feel like a
chore to get to the best of was content
with Legion it's hard to remember when
Wow's narrative and questing were ever
this strong before and time will tell if
Blizzard will serve up a healthy dose of
new content to keep the expansion
in-game alive or if it will suffer the
fate of warlords of draenor but right
now Blizzard has proven it can still
craft an MMO experience as well as if
not better than anyone else there is
something I must do first